a strong recovery will ultimately enable
the Fed to reduce its monetary
accommodation and its reliance on
unconventional policy tools such as
asset purchases I believe that
supporting the recovery today is the
surest path to returning to a more
normal approach to monetary policy do
you have any estimate right now as to
when there may be a beginning of the
tapering well we at each meeting are
attempting to assess whether or not we
are seeing we have seen meaningful
progress in the labor market and what
the committee is looking for is signs
that we will have growth that's strong
enough to promote continued progress
what I would not support is a
requirement that we any requirement that
would diminish the independence of the
Federal Reserve in implementing and
deciding on implementing in monetary
policy I would be very concerned about
legislation that would subject the
Federal Reserve to short-term political
pressures that could interfere with that
independence and do believe that a
default on the you on the u.s. debt
would be catastrophic and we did see
some signs in the run-up to the debt
ceiling that suggested that financial
markets were taking notice we are very
focused on achieving our dual mandate
which is we absolutely want to avoid
deflation we have a two percent price
stability objective we're trying to get
the economy back to full employment I do
think we've made progress but we're not
there yet